my talk of the table is
a real live person and she's here big
news for the women's shapewear company
what's her name
sarah blakely she started spanx a
groundbreaking business more than two
decades ago and now she's selling a
majority stake of the company into a
global investment firm blackstone the
deal values her company listen to this
number 1.2 billion with the b dollars
blakely we're happy to say will maintain
a significant equity stake in spanx and
will become executive chairwoman on the
company's board did you hear me chair
woman she founded the company in 2000
with listen to this five thousand
dollars in her savings that she earned
by selling fax machines she got the idea
for spanx when she wanted a control top
to wear under her pants white pants at
the time so you wouldn't have a panty
line so she cut the feet off of a pair
of pantyhose and spanx eureka was born
and we thank her ever since in 2012 at
the age of 41 sarah blakely was named
the youngest self-made female
billionaire by forbes magazine and she
is here sarah badass blakely joins us at
the table so do we call you sarah did
they call you badass do we call you
madame blakely or do you what what do
you prefer sarah's fire is okay i go
there's a lot of titles mom
sarah sarah b the beast dance for
billiards yeah of course i love that i
like that sarah congratulations thank
you gail such a huge huge moment for
your company it is now this isn't the
first time you've been approached to
sell the company no i mean for the whole
20 years i've owned it 21 years people
have been asking to invest in it buy the
business in fact right after i started
the company for the first six months all
these people kept coming up to me and
saying what's your exit strategy and i
didn't even know what an exit strategy
was gail i finally one day was like my
exit strategies i want to exit a room
and look good yeah and then they would
leave me alone but i did you know i'd
never taken a business class so all
these people saying how are you going to
exit 21 years ago i was like why didn't
you thought about it why did you decide
though sarah now is the time because
they're a skeptic of saying well she has
a lot of competition now maybe she's
worried but the company is still doing
very very well the company's doing
amazing competition had nothing to do
with this decision i operate off of gut
and intuition and i knew that i would
just know when it was the right time
when it was the right time for the
business when it was the right time for
me personally and the business is like
at this amazing point we've expanded
into so many things other than shapewear
and bringing in blackstone with global
resources it's like a really awesome
time
for the business but you go ahead and my
baby's 21. 20.
it's already it's already not only gone
to college it's out of college and now i
can legally drink it's like it's like
when your baby's still living in your
house at 21 you start asking yourself
maybe i should let it spread its wings
and go out into the world 21 is a long
time it was 20 years ago that it was an
oprah pick for one of oprah's favorite
things i mean 20 years is a long enough
time for people to start thinking
differently and a new generation to come
along and i'm curious we talk a lot
about body positivity these days
accepting oneself loving oneself
our spanx and all the related spin-off
products that people have copied you uh
at making part of body positivity are
those compatible ideas i mean for me
they are i wear spanx because i don't
want a panty line like i want it's for
me it's a smooth canvas under my clothes
and where do you draw the line on
highlighting your hair and makeup and
all the things that we do that make us
feel better and
be able to wear the clothes that we want
to wear i mean it started because i i
had cream pants hanging in my closet and
everything showed under it but this was
a male business when you first very much
so were you i would imagine you were not
taken seriously when you first started
out no walk into amazing is it an
advantage
i always say i think being a woman in
business uh our weakness and strength is
being underestimated and so for me in
the beginning because nobody took me
serious for quite a long time i was able
to start creating far better options i
mean 21 years ago i stood in a factory
floor no business experience and said i
want to create this product for myself
so i can wear these pants that hung in
my closet unworn
then i looked around the room i was the
only woman in the room and i thought the
people who are making our undergarments
aren't spending all day in them yes and
i want to be the one to speak up and say
we can make these far more comfortable
and so then i kind of started advocating
for women through product and that's how
21 years later we're still trying to
make things better for women i've always
said under underestimate me and i'll
over deliver yeah um now you speak on
creating this product and why you did
this is business 101 supply demand there
are individuals out there young men and
women that are thinking about starting a
business yeah and you created it because
you wanted to what advice would you give
to those out there that are saying i
want to follow my passion yeah i'm
hesitant but sarah talk about two five
thousand dollars of your own money yeah
never it's now a billion dollar company
you've never taken anybody's money for
this company
i never took any outside investment for
21 years
and um so to answer a question for
people who are thinking about it people
start businesses i think for two reasons
you can make something better that
already exists or you have an idea that
doesn't already exist so if you're
sitting on either one of those you got
to go for it you know i had no
experience i say that when you don't
have experience that can be your
greatest asset if you'll let it because
it ensures you're going to do things
differently than how they've been done
like if you're just following how
everyone else is doing it where's the
change so i just yeah so i would say go
for it if you're if you're addressing
those two things you've essentially
created you essentially created this
category shapewear right now all these
people have copied you how were you able
to keep the company at the front with
all of these people saying that's a
great idea i'll do it too good question
product
i never took my eye off of product
product is the north star we don't
compromise on fit shapewear is really
easy to make and really hard to get
right yeah and so we have never stopped
that we've had competition for 20 years
people usually come in the arena for
about two years and then exit the arena
they go this is hard this is hard but
you know and now i'm so excited about
where the company's heading i mean we're
set over 70 of our business is digital
now and we make denim we make leather
you know faux leather leggings and
apparel the consumers have been saying
for me too as well yeah yeah minx the
magic that you put into the spanx shape
where to define the category i was gonna
say that best event
i was gonna ask you you don't have to
suck it in all day tony i was gonna ask
if gail's the only one of the tables
thanks but i today she flashed me her
spending yeah they're called keepers
they're still flashing your spanx aren't
they that's what we call them yeah
they're called compression shorts and
they're for athletic professionals
okay sarah the other big thing about
this deal is was all female on both
sides yes thank you for your team yes
and the blackstone team yeah all women
and that's huge huge deal blackstone had
an all-female deal team
headed up by ann chong who's amazing and
we were so aligned on the mission of
being able to elevate women support
women and what we want to do in the
future for the brand you are an
inspiration you really are
congratulations on everything thank you
thank you so much for joining us